[Music]
the king's man is the third kingsman
movie but it's not kingsman 3. here's
everything you need to know about the
roliking prequel and the future of the
kingsman franchise
the date and title of the third kingsman
movie ended up changing during the
production process at first the film was
announced with the working title
kingsman the great game eventually it
was decided that it would instead be
titled the king's man which is a good
fit it references the original films
while still making it clear that this
movie will be different originally the
release date for the king's man was
planned for november 15 2019. however
the date was pushed back to valentine's
day 2020 so that fox could give that
prime award season spot to ford vs
ferrari it was pushed back yet again to
september 18th and then came the covet
19 pandemic that global disruption in
movie exhibition pushed the king's man
back yet again this time all the way to
december 22nd 2021 better late than
never right
matthew vaughn who directed both
kingsmen the secret service and its
sequel the golden circle is getting
behind the camera again for the king's
man bon said during a panel discussion
at new york comic-con i wanted to
scratch a niche that i've had for ages
in making a movie like the big epic
adventure films that i grew up on making
a movie like that on this sort of scale
is not exactly easy to raise money for
so i thought if i entwined that into the
king's man universe hollywood wouldn't
be as scared of it bond named lawrence
of arabia the man who would be king and
the english patient as films that
inspired his vision for the king's man
while the secret service and the golden
circle took place in modern times and
feature the kingsman organization
dealing with contemporary issues the
king's man is going to be a prequel to
those films set against the backdrop of
world war 1. why did bond decide to work
on a prequel rather than jumping
straight into working on another sequel
according to the director himself he saw
it as an opportunity to start with a
blank canvas rather than building on the
previous films he told entertainment
weekly in 2019 it's hard to do plot
twists with characters that are known so
i wanted to do an origin movie that had
hardly anything to do with the original
kingsman he also says that you can watch
and enjoy the king's man even if you
haven't seen the other kingsman films
yet
since the king's band takes place so
many years before the events of the
secret service in the golden circle
taryn edgerton and colin firth will not
be returning to their starring roles as
eggsy and harry although a kingsman film
without edgerton and firth will
definitely have a different tone this
gives vaughn the chance to bring some
fresh faces into the fold and go in a
new direction with this film plus both
actors have been quite busy lately
edgerton starred as elton john in the
musical biopic rocket man which earned
overwhelmingly positive reviews from
critics and even generated some oscar
buzz more recently he voiced rihann and
the netflix jim henson puppet series the
dark crystal age of resistance and his
voice will be heard again in sing too in
which he'll return as johnny the gorilla
as for firth his recent roles include
the war drama 1917 as well as the secret
garden and supernova clearly not adverse
to acting through big scale conflict
he's also set to appear in another war
drama operation mincemeat
the king's man is a period film that
offers an alternative take on the events
of world war one leading up to the
establishment of the kingsman
organization proper it largely centers
on two characters harris dickinson's
conrad and his father ray finds his
orlando the duke of oxford we definitely
know that it's a period film set during
world war one but judging by the
irreverent tone of the previous kingsman
films it's not going to be a
run-of-the-mill historical drama
this gentleman's [ __ ] i'm gonna love
calling you harris dickinson is starring
in the king's man as conrad whose
aspirations to become a soldier and
fights in the global conflict end up
leading him in a very different
direction than he or his father
originally intended dickinson has raved
about his experience shooting the king's
man the actor said that he felt like he
had lots of creative freedom in his role
with the movie telling a new story that
doesn't rely on the previous films to
make sense in an interview with collider
dickinson said it's not like the
pressure of a sequel necessarily where
you've got to come in and continue the
story ray finds will play conrad's
father the duke of oxford and the
founder of the kingsman organization he
acts as a mentor to conrad throughout
the film teaching his son that while the
government might not take action to stop
injustice in time kingsmen can his
opinion is that espionage is a more
effective way of fighting than using
brute force not that his son necessarily
believes it
real power
is not found running off to war
fines told comicbook.com his son's
growing up and is full of a sense of
duty and wanting to prove himself as a
soldier and as a man of honor i try to
give him another perspective how you can
do more damage to the enemy by the right
intelligence and undercover work than
all-out war
the cast of the king's man is rounded
out by several accomplished actors gemma
arterton who recently lent her voice to
the tv adaptation of the novel watership
down will have a leading role as polly a
classy sharpshooter connected to the
proto-kingsman group jimin honsu known
as korath and marvel films like captain
marvel and guardians of the galaxy is
also involved in the adventure playing a
swashbuckling character by the name of
shola aaron taylor johnson is set to
play lee unwin a soldier who considering
the surname is likely one of eggsy
unwin's ancestors the movie's marketing
also predominantly features rhys ephons
known for his work as dr kirk connors
aka the lizard in the amazing spider-man
as well as an appearance in harry potter
and the deathly hallows part 1 as
xenophilius lovegood in the king's men
ethons will appear as a notorious
russian rasputin getting up to more
close quarters combat than you ever
would have expected while the kingsman
was still in production it was reported
that liam neeson would be appearing in
the film nissan did seem like a great
fit for a kingsman film but this casting
news was only a rumor bond told the
playlist back in 2019 i just rap the
movie and unless he's got some amazing
prosthetics and he's playing some
character i didn't know about he ain't
in the film never had a discussion i
love liam neeson and i'd love for him to
be in it but no i have no idea where
that came from
the king's man may be a prequel but that
doesn't mean we'll never find out what
happened to our modern day heroes after
the events of the golden circle vaughn
has already confirmed that another
kingsman film is in the works king's men
the blue blood which will be released in
the future picking up where the golden
circle left off a script from the movie
is reportedly already written and as far
as the plot is concerned bond said that
audiences should quote expect the
unexpected and this time taryn edgerton
and colin firth will be back as eggsy
and harry edgerton has said he's glad
he'll get a chance to return to the role
and he's hoping that the new film will
fare better with the critics than the
golden circle edgerton told empire i
would like the third one to be better
received than the second one was i felt
we got a bit of an unfair kicking if i'm
totally honest what i would like to
happen is for us to do a third one and
for it to feel like a worthy third
installment to what has been a great
part of my life there is also reportedly
a kingsman spin-off film in development
under the title of statesman this film
would presumably be all about kingsmen's
american counterpart organization by
that name which was featured prominently
in the golden circle
[Music]
that'll make you want to slap your mama
right there boy if the upcoming kingsman
films still aren't enough for you you're
in luck there's also reportedly a
kingsman television series planned the
series will supposedly include eight
hour long episodes but as of right now
there's very little info out about the
series it's simply known as the untitled
kingsman project and there's no release
date yet production on the show has not
yet started and there's no word about
who the cast will be basically we're in
the dark for now although vaughn
reportedly has quote something like
seven more kingsman films up his sleeve
if you're feeling a bit impatient about
the upcoming projects you can always
check out the animated archer and
kingsman crossover titled tbt to that
time archer met kingsman you probably
shouldn't tell people you're a spy then
what's the point in being one fair
enough the short features eggsy
alongside sterling archer with edgerton
voicing eggsy archer happens to find the
secret kingsman lair and outsmarts eggsy
at his own game during a drinking
contest
beat that
with so many things in the works fans
will be getting plenty of new material
for years to come there's still much to
explore in the world of kingsman check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you